hello and welcome to this video playing
yeah now I'm not trying anything not
trying to pronounce that how would our
Bobby okay I'm going for a simple
opening here the Tory attack okay Wow
okay again what what what the heck am I
not just a pawn up here with that pretty
good position okay oh no I wanted to
take on p7 oh my god I wanted to take on
b7 yeah I mean am i oh my god yeah I I
wanted to take on p7 and it's just just
about when i was i was thinking away if
i take that it was good of course but
well maybe there are other moves yeah
let's say a picture of c4 or something I
mean blacks position is very very loose
and yeah exactly next position is very
very loose and Bishop c4 is indeed good
it did a good move but when i was i was
putting it back it somehow yeah it's
somehow how does it do it actually if I
from some of the software point of view
so I do this and
has it if it's this and puts it back it
has to be just like just slightly there
then it already is a move yeah so okay
what a crazy game okay I understand that
this is not really a full fledged full
fledged video but I think it was so
funny i'll upload it anyway i hope you
got a lot out of that even though this
is basically just just two games for
that for that up for that to daily
upload thanks for watching